se esperaba Tal vez un pronunciamiento
más amplio acerca de la situación en
este país por qué tal vez sólo fue uno
de los presidentes el que tomó la
vocería aribel
estamos viendo que América Latina a la
vez está dividida en diferentes Américas
latinas Andrés es decir si bien es
cierto que se ha tenido de gobiernos de
izquierda no todos precisamente están
hacia la misma directriz hemos visto ya
también en otros espacios y en otros
foros donde los mismos mandatarios que
son de izquierda no precisamente
coinciden están eh teniendo un choque de
opiniones y esta Cumbre no fue la
excepción Andrés Me parece que hay que
condenar enérgicamente no solo las
acciones por parte del mandatario Ortega
y Nicaragua sino también la forma de la
violación de los Derechos Humanos en
Venezuela y también en Cuba sin embargo
pues eh presidente cubano sí estuvo
presente El ausente fue el venezolano
estamos viendo un América Latina
y y pensando básicamente en iberoamérica
muy polarizada muy dividida
tuvimos entre Ayer hoy en esta Cumbre y
justo lo que se necesita Pues es que
dentro de estas diferencias que se va a
detener Andrés porque no siempre los
países tienen que coincidir en todo se
vale externar lo que se ve desde afuera
pero lo importante es construir a partir
de las coincidencias y yo creo que hacia
allá hacia donde tienen ahora los
mandatarios que apostarle no haciendo
berrinches no molestándose porque al
final de cuentas la comunidad
internacional eso es se vale hacer
señalamientos porque no se están
cumpliendo ni la carta de las Naciones
Unidas ni tampoco la declaración
universal de los Derechos Humanos donde
la mayoría de estos países pues son
signatarios así que vaya importantes
palabras que mencionó el presidente
chileno Andrés pero sin duda no es el
único país que está violando los
Derechos Humanos me refiero
específicamente a Nicaragua